how would you handle it if you were
working on a project with great people
magical great chemistry
but they're a little bit behind on
paying you
how would you approach that
what what do you mean by a little bit
behind
a couple months
if i'd be a long project um
i'd hand it off to my agent i'd tell my
agent to deal with it you know and have
they have a legal team and i
i would i would keep doing i mean i i
certainly wouldn't
confront any of my creative partners or
probably even tell them about it um i
mean i might if i felt they would have
influence with the production company
you know but i wouldn't threaten them i
wouldn't be one of those guys like i'm
going to walk off
you know again i'm committed to the work
first and even if even if those bastards
never paid me i'd i'd finish the job and
never work with them again
you know but but but to me somebody
else's bad behavior is not a license for
me to also have bad behavior
um you know again if somebody's being
unsafe if somebody's being jeopardized
you know or harassed
or harmed that would be different i
would certainly
you know become defensive and
confrontational in that
responsibility you know as as
you know to whatever degree was was
necessary in the moment but you know by
and large i believe in
diplomacy and professionalism
and and if it's just that my pay is late
um
i certainly wouldn't be happy about it
but i'm not going to harm the work and
i'm not going to harm my relationship
with the parties who are not directly
involved in that
you know predicament
how about earlier in your career when
you did not have an agent
well
you know it would it would still be a
similar strategy but i
i would not jeopardize my position on
the project i would i would not go into
defcon mode until after the project
wrapped
you know and even then i wouldn't be you
know impolitic about it i would you know
i would be professional i would you know
i would give them notice and then i
would either get a lawyer or i would
you know file a complaint
with the labor board you know i would
you know do the right things if i was in
the union i would you know or i mean i i
am in the union now but if i was at the
time i would report it to the union and
that's the other thing too is if i was
on that job in addition to seeking my
agent on them i would stick the union on
them um but but if i was all on my own i
would like i said i would just wait
until
you know i would not be happy but i
would put up with it until we were done
and then i would go through
the you know the legal avenues available
to me
and and if i ended up getting boned in
the end and even if i didn't even if
they ended up paying if i had a bad
experience and felt they were being
predatory i would just never work with
them again
you know to answer that it's like look
you know in in withholding my pay
they're already harming me right
you know but if i pee in my own well
then that's adding harm you know if i if
i
um provoke them in such a way that they
spread you know bad stories about me
even if they're in the wrong i don't
know who they know
you know if if the producer or the
director or my you know the actors you
know if i create a situation
where they think i have some bad
behavior you know that's gonna harm me i
don't you know there's no value in that
to me that's just that's just adding
adding my own harm to it
um and i just don't think it's gonna
improve it and that's that's just based
on my value because again i'm their
first and foremost for the work and the
relationships
how much time do you spend each day
improving your craft as a
cinematographer well see that's one of
those formula questions there's there's
just no formulas there is no
bullet point on my calendar every day
i nebulously engage you know i read the
news i read imdb pro news i
engage on social media i belong to
networking groups i belong to
you know
groups specifically about film lenses i
belong to cinematographer groups i
belong to
professional groups like the canadian
society cinematographers the visual
effects society and you know i l what
are people talking about you know what
are the articles they're posting i might
come across an article and post it
um so it it's really i mean i do my due
diligence and i do my check-ins
but if if if it's a day where there's
really nothing
on those boards or on the news then then
i probably don't do too much if it's a
day that there's significant amounts of
stuff you know if i have the time then
then i'll be watching some videos and
reading some articles um you know
maybe bookmarking if i don't have the
time uh you know i do i do i'll do
webinars and and workshops and you know
in in a normal area era where we're not
in a in a pandemic i'll go to trade
shows and product demos
which you know in as much as they're
important you know to learning about
your craft and the new technologies
they're also networking opportunities
um and it's fun to me it's not it's not
it's not work i mean again these are
these are toys it's like what's the new
toy what's the cool thing you know it's
you know instead of a 4k camera you have
an 8k camera and why should i care you
know and um
you know now you've got these affordable
anamorphic lenses where did those come
from and how are they different from the
you know
tens of thousands of dollars lenses and
uh um you know now you've got these rgb
leds that could do any color under the
sun and they can do a cop light and they
can do a strobe and they can do
you know fire flicker and i just i love
that because cool that's a new toy and i
you know either rent it or go out and
buy it um so
again there's no i can't tell you how
many hours a day but but it's certainly
you know
one of my focuses it's one of the things
that uh that that um you know just like
when somebody reads the news they check
you know the the the national section
and the international section and the
the comics and the one ads for instance
it's like you know that's one of those
things that you know every day i'm like
okay what's you know what do i need to
check with
how much time do you spend trying to
book your next job
i could say 24 7 considering i have a
website
you know i have i have posts and
and and social media identities on
linkedin and you know to me that's like
little fish poles with bait that are
stuck out into the into the water 24 7.
um
you know i i network i plant those seeds
i have people out there that i hope are
recommending me and saying good things
you know maybe you would call that
passive but to me that's all
you know
sometimes those would get me more work
than me picking up a phone or or asking
or going to lunch you know it's those
it's those those ripples you put out
into the world you know just like you
obviously did your research on my
website i didn't have anything to do
with that
um i mean i created it but i you know
you and i didn't talk about it
um
in terms of in terms of me personally
you know it really depends on the days
um when when when california christmas
was blowing up i was looking at imdb
films in pre-production and just
reaching out to people you know because
i thought you know now's the moment i
can you know reach out and say hey i've
got a number one film
um
but you have to balance that you know
with life and i could easily be a
workaholic as i've already kind of let
you know that i would work through meals
and through the night um
and you know
i
network and and hustle
far more
than i shoot you know there's this great
quote by uh
um
orson welles
um and it's something to the effect that
you know he
he he
probably made a mistake becoming a
filmmaker um because it's you know two
percent making movies and 98
begging for the money to make them i'm
paraphrasing but that's the essence of
part of that quote
um
and and it really is i mean so much of
our work is getting work what i i like
to tell people that i am professionally
unemployed
because what most people do only a few
times in their life in between jobs
i do constantly even when i'm on a job
i'm looking for work you know
so so really if you looked at how i
spend the hours in in my day
i'm professionally unemployed
when you first started out was it the
same percentage of time that you were
looking for work
absolutely not and and that's naivete
you know i really felt
build it and they will come
you know i really felt that um
i mean i had never been a freelancer
before i didn't understand the dynamic
of working as a freelancer i didn't
understand the importance of networking
i had only ever worked for a company
where they
meet you once and they hire you and then
you just keep showing up and you know
doing the time card until you quit or
get fired
um
so it really was a huge learning curve
for me and and there were a lot of
illusions just like when i moved to los
angeles i thought oh you know it's a
huge city somebody's going to hire me
somebody's going to give me a job and i
was so
full of
you know and i guess mercifully so
because because if i really realized how
hard it was going to be would i have
done it
probably but it i wouldn't have been as
hopeful and optimistic it would have
been more oppressive to live with the
reality of what lay ahead of me instead
of being blissfully ignorant
do you think working at these temp jobs
prepared you because it's the same thing
like when you would work at these temp
jobs and one of these things would end
and okay accounting doesn't need you
anymore i don't know what you were doing
but
and then you had to go and let the temp
company know i'm available this week
yeah i mean
in little ways i think because
because like you could wait for them to
call you if they had a job for you
but you could also wake up at 6 00 a.m
and call and say i'm available and you
were more likely to get something you
know so there was that incentive be
proactive you know
and um
i'm not a morning person i mean left to
my own devices i wake up at 10 so for me
to wake up at 6 00 a.m that was a super
human feat
it's not so hard if it's a call time and
i'm getting paid but you know just to
call you know wake up and make a call
because maybe i'll get paid to go to a
job that i really don't want to do
oh my god yes well you know
we also don't want to go to the clinic
and get shots but we have to so it's
just you know i'm at that age now you
have to get a colonoscopy every five
years it's i'd rather go to disneyland
but you know there are things in life
you have to do and and when i was out
here calling the temp agency at 6am was
one of them and it was you know again it
was a good habit it was discipline it's
like you know do that thing you don't
want to do because you have to you know
no your boss isn't telling you to and
your
mom and dad and girlfriend aren't
telling you to and if you don't
nobody's going to be mad at you you just
aren't going to work
you